what's up everybody thank you for
joining us at candid truth we're going
to talk about the truth and we're going
to get candid with it if you guys didn't
know last weekend just a couple of days
ago the UN had a meeting and they were
signing some things that we didn't give
our consent to and some of the things
that they were signing were very
Sinister and grim and it looks like the
end is near I was actually watching a
live um footage of it today and a woman
talking even was talking about how the
end is near and it's so interesting that
it used to be Christians that were out
on the street holding that cardboard
sign the end is near and they were
called crazies they were called the Cs
but now the world is flip-flopped and
now it's the secular world that's saying
the end is near the Christians are
asleep and they're not able to see the
signs of the times but the secular world
is saying that the end is near that
climate change is going to destroy the
world and if we don't do something now
if we don't make some changes fast we're
running out of time there are climate
clocks popping up all over the the
cities of the world and years ago it
said we had seven years left I think now
that's down to probably two or three
years they're seeing something and
they're saying the end is near if we
don't if we don't make some changes now
I don't agree with any of this stuff I
think there's a huge agenda I think that
the global elitist are pulling the
strings and they are just
uh creating fear in people so that they
can have total enslavement we know this
is true according to Bible prophecy if
you read the book of Revelation you will
see that there is a government called a
beast system that's going to have power
over all the nations of the world and
he's going to have a one world
government a One World Currency a one
world religion and we are racing towards
that right now I want you to check this
out I want you to read this with me so
this is straight from the UN .org and it
says United Nations information service
and here's where they're talking about
day one they're talking about each day
is youth lead for future so they're
always packaging up this thing like it's
it's the good it's for the common good
it's for the Youth of our world and and
the youth is our future and I believe in
all that stuff this is how Satan Works
he works in deception right Satan
doesn't come out and say I want to make
slaves of the whole world no he he
packages it up and pretty little package
you wouldn't drink a bottle of bleach
but if I gave you a a glass of ice cold
lemonade and I put a couple of drops of
bleach in there you would drink it right
up this is how Satan Works he speaks in
99% truth but 99% truth is not truth
when he spoke to Eve in the garden he
said did not God say you could eat of
every tree of the garden but he left off
that one little part about not this tree
right so this is how Satan speaks and it
says press release United Nations adopts
groundbreaking pack for the future to
transform Global governances this is
crazy this is hot right off the press
it's just happen to
transform Global governances this isn't
talking look Global governances where
did this come from we are different
nations of the world we make our own
laws even in different states we make
our own laws right Texas has laws that
wouldn't even fly over in California
right because everything is is divided
but now there they're using this
terminology Global
governances says New York 20 uh
September 23 this just happened today
September 24 so September 23 world
leaders yesterday September 22 is when
it happened adopt a pack for a future
that includes a global dig digital
Compact and a declaration on future
Generations you're telling me an impact
on future Generations this PCT is the co
ation of an inclusive yearslong process
to adapt International cooperation
International cooperation we need to
come that's what the United Nations is
all about the UN uniting all the nations
of the world we know this is wrong it
sounds good it sounds like coexist and
Kumbaya and peace and love but we're
going to see from scripture that this is
exactly what's going to happen when the
end
comes the culmination of years long
process to adapt International
cooperations to to the realities of
today and the challenges of Tomorrow the
most wide ranging International
agreement in many years covering
entirely new areas as well as issues on
which agreement has not been possible in
decades that's true because we never had
this kind of Technology The Pact aims
above all to ensure that International
institutions can deliver in the face of
a world that has changed dramatically
since they were created as the Secretary
General has said listen to this
statement we cannot create a future fit
for our grandchildren with a system
built by our grandparents they're saying
look this all these old rules we got to
change everything but that's not the way
God made it God made perfect laws that
last forever and if we were to follow
those rules and those laws we live in a
perfect world and they're saying no we
need to change everything that
Constitution get rid of it it's old we
don't need that anymore we need a one
world religion a One World Government
One World Currency that's where all this
is headed and it gets even crazier when
it gets into the
AI overall the agreement of The Pact is
a strong statement of country's
commitment to the United Nations the
International System and international
law international law leaders set out a
Clear Vision of an international system
that can deliver on its promises is more
representative of today's world and
draws on the energy and expertise of
governments civil society and other key
Partners the pack for the future this is
a quote the pack for the future the
government digital Compact and the
Declaration of on the future Generations
open the door to New Opportunities and
untapped possibilities said Secretary
General during his remarks on the
opening of the summit of the future the
president of the general assembly noted
that the pack would lay the foundations
for the sustainable just for the
sustainable just and peaceful Global
Order this is in this sounds so dark and
Sinister if you have been awake for a
while like many of us have my Awakening
was December 2011 when I realized that
there is uh a shadow government there is
Satan is in control that he's in control
the the president is nothing he's a face
he's a there's an illusion of Freedom
that you have the freedom to choose
who's president but it's just going to
alternate back and forth it's going to
be four years Republican four years
Democrat they're just trying to appease
you and keep you from causing an
uprising and then when uh you know
you're sick of four years they like okay
we'll give you your guy but nothing ever
changes it's a two steps forward one
step back agenda the agenda is going to
roll out it's
prophetic and they're saying that
there's going to be a global order a new
world order but we know that's not true
this is order out of chaos they're
trying to create chaos so that we will
be in utter fear and we're going to cry
out we we need change we need something
and they're going to say we got
something for you total enslavement says
the pack covers a a broad range of
issues including peace and security
sustainable development climate change
of course digital cooperation human
rights gender of course Youth and future
generations and the transformation of
global governance Global governance key
deliverables in The Pact include in the
area of peace and security think of
those words peace and security where
have we heard that in the Bible I'm
going to pull it up right now 1
Thessalonians 53 says for when they
shall say peace in safety they said
Peace and security when they shall say
peace and safety then sudden destruction
cometh upon them as travail upon a woman
with child and they shall not escape
this is the end times we are literally
living in it we're seeing it happen
right now it says the most Progressive
and concrete commitment to security
uh Council reform since the 1960s with
plans to improve the effectiveness and
representatives of the council including
by redressing the historical
commitment to the goal of totally
eliminating nuclear weapons sounds great
right agreement to strengthen the
international framework the Govern the
that govern outer space now we're going
to govern outer space including a clear
commitment to prevent an arms race in
outer space and the need to ensure all
countries can benefit from the safe and
sustainable exploration of outer space
we need that we all need to be able to
explore outer space right steps to avoid
the weaponization and misuse of tech of
new technologies really I think the new
technologies are being used against us
right now such as lethal autonomous
weapons and affirmation that the laws of
war should apply to many of these new
technologies so now we're going to talk
about on sustainable development climate
and finances for development and I'm
actually going to skip past that because
I don't even buy into this but basically
they're talking about um you know better
getting rid of fossil fuels and having
zero emissions by 2050 I'm actually okay
with that you know if we had uh if we
would have stuck with nickola Tesla's
technology we could have all had free
energy that was being pumped out into
the airwaves like Wi-Fi and it was
completely harmless but these uh Rich
fat cats that were actually funding him
to build these structures to make it
happen started realizing wait a minute
you want to tear down all my power poles
and people aren't going to have to pay
for for energy and they stopped funing
him halfway through and they would
electrocute elephants in the Public
Square and say this is what his
technology was doing and yet he went
right up to these uh electric metal
balls and put his hand on both of them
and electricity was flying off of him in
all directions and it didn't hurt him
because it was a it was a it was a safe
effective free technology a free energy
source on digital cooperation the Global
digital compact annexed to The Pact is
the first comprehensive Global framework
for digital cooperation and AI
governance did you hear that we're
talking about global AI governance
governing the whole world because they
want to make a a world where it's all
under the same rule a One World
Government run by AI this is if you
don't if you've never seen the the movie
trans Terminator if you seen the
Terminator movie this is Skynet all the
way that's exactly what Skynet was a
neural net based artificial intelligence
it was the allseeing eye of AI and it
looked over humanity and realized that
Humanity was The Pest of the earth and
it actually engaged all the nukes of the
world to destroy Humanity just wipe them
out now I'm not buying into that but I
do believe that we should not be
governed by
AI um and because you don't
know who is in control of the AI who is
in control of This Global government I
don't believe these are people we can
trust I don't believe these are people
who have our good at in in their
interest you know who is the last
trustworthy president leader King that
you can think of was it King Herod was
it Pharaoh was it Hitler was it Stalin
which one none of them have ever been
good and here we are we're we're trying
to make a Global government that's
controlled by AI that can literally
watch every single keystroke you make
that can literally transcribe this live
broadcast right now and can flag certain
words and what's what's going to happen
next if you get flagged on your YouTube
channel a robot comes knocking on your
door and sends you to to Camp somewhere
this is where we're
at at the heart of the compact is the is
a commitment to design use and govern
technology for the benefit of all this
includes commitments by world leaders to
connect all people schools hospitals to
the internet we're going to connect all
people schools and hospitals to the
internet how are we going to do that I
mean right now we all have phones we're
already all connected right is this
talking about Biometrics is this talking
about neuron link or something how are
they connecting all people because what
they're going to say is look we have to
do this this we don't know uh if there's
a terrorist living next door to you and
we want to keep you safe and so we need
everyone to have a chip in their brain
so that we can know their thoughts this
is like Minority Report this is like
born identity the all these dystopian
scii movies are coming true and it's all
going to be it's all going to roll out
under fear because when when people have
fear like this they're willing to do
anything to to feel safe and protected
and a lot of people give up a lot of
freedoms when they feel unsafe anchor
digital cooperation in human rights and
international law here's that again make
the online space safe for all especially
children I I like that idea I like the
idea that there is there would be no
orography none let's get rid of it let's
make it safe for children let's
eliminate the sex trafficking that's
going on in videos that is actually one
of the most wealthiest businesses on
Earth let's eliminate that and make the
internet safe for children but that's
not what they're talking about they're
talking about uh protecting children
from misinformation disinformation Mal
information you know if if you get
online and you talk about natural
remedies and cures for things you could
be deemed a terrorist and we need to get
rid of you because you're unsafe you're
making the internet an unsafe place it
says especially children through actions
by governments Tech compan companes and
social media see you're not even going
to be able to speak your mind on social
media no more freedom of speech govern
artificial intelligence with a road map
that includes an international
scientific panel an international
scientific panel I don't even trust the
science that's out there if you do think
and if you're a Christian and you say
you trust the science out there just
look at a science textbook that says uh
the earth started from nothing that
exploded and this expanding Perfection
of our universe came from a nothing a
big bang and some primordial soup
evolved and you were a one cell amoeba
that swam around until you could crawl
out on land and became a rat and then a
monkey and then finally a human this is
what science is teaching this on an
international level this is taught
worldwide so if it's making us uh if
it's artificial intelligence that is
governed by international science panel
and a global policy Dialogue on a
then I don't think we can trust this
make data more open and accessible with
agreements on open-source data models
and standards this is also the first
Global commitment to data governance
data governance oh uh let's see what you
got on your computer we're going to
govern that we're going to govern your
data you can't have that on your
computer a Bible wait a minute that's
hate speech get rid of that placing it
on the UN Agenda and requiring countries
to take concrete actions by 203 13 we're
about to roll up on 2025 I know five
years sounds like a long time but it's
really not it's going to be in the blink
of an eye and it doesn't matter if it's
five years or 10 years it's still coming
it's the impending doom that's that's
rolling out we need to be we need to
wake up we need to take this stuff
serious we need to pay attention to
what's going on because this is how they
do this stuff they they do it on the
weekend when you're not paying attention
and they say oh you didn't know about
that yeah you wait you didn't uh agree
to that well it doesn't matter we're the
global government we do what we want to
it's a
global uh it's a
global dictatorship they make the rules
Youth and future Generations the first
ever Declaration on future generations
with concrete steps to take account of
future generations and our
decisionmaking including a possible
Envoy for future Generations a
commitment to more meaningful
opportunities for young people to
participate at in the decisions that
shape their lives especially at the
global level human rights and gender
this has to happen now right now that
there's how many genders are there now
60 something a strengthening of our work
on human rights gender equality and the
empowerment of women look I'm all about
equal rights with women I'm not against
that it's this gender equality thing
that's a more ambiguous language notice
it says gender equality and the
empowerment of women that's two
different things and so gender equality
this is where it's imposing on my
freedoms as someone who you know maybe a
cake maker doesn't want to make a cake
for an lgbtq wedding well now you're
going to get shut down because that's
not gender
equality uh this goes into all kinds of
things here you you must you must uh
respect my pronouns or you could be
locked up because that's hate speech and
and you're you're a bully you're you're
calling me a man because I was born a
male but I identify as a woman you are a
bully and you need to be locked up a
clear call on the need to protect human
rights Defenders strong signals on the
importance of Engagement of other
stakeholders and and Global governance
including local and Regional governments
Civil Society private sector and
others there are Provisions Across The
Pact and its annexes for followup action
to ensue that the commitments made are
implemented Summit process the summit
process and The Pact have been deeply
enriched by the contributions of
millions of voices and thousands of
stakeholders from around the world the
Sumit brought together over 4,000
individuals from heads of state and
government observers igos un systems uh
civil society and non-governmental
organizations in a broader push to
increase the engagement of of diverse
actors the formal Summit was preceded by
the actions by the action days from 20
to uh you know 2020 to 2021
September or wait September 20 through
21 which attracted more than 7,000
individuals representing all segments of
society the action days featured strong
commitments to action by all
stakeholders as well as pledges of 1.05
billion doll to advance digital
inclusions this is serious guys this is
literally Skynet in real life this is
everything you do is being tracked and
monitored and governed by artificial
intelligence this is the world of
enslavement this is what the Bible
talked about though so I get excited
when I see this kind of stuff
because um let me scroll through here I
get excited when I hear this stuff
because this is Bible prophecy coming
true and if there were any Skeptics in
the world those Skeptics should now be
asking serious questions wait a minute
I've been hearing this all my life
growing up I remember those crazy
preachers that were saying that one day
there was going to be a one world order
a One World Government a one world
religion and I I also remember that
there was going to be Wars and
pestilences and famines like no other
and I remember that the Bible said
something about peace and safety but
sudden destru instruction is going to
come upon them it's time to wake up and
God is pleading with the world and he's
saying I gave you prophecy so that you
would not be taken over by deception
it's our responsibility to get in the
word of God and open it up and search
for truth like
gold I want to read some more from the
word of God
here in Matthew 24 this is a famous
chapter about the end of the world and
there asking Jesus uh what's going to
happen when you come back and Jesus says
take heed that no man deceive you it's
about deception remember peace and
safety but that's not true it's
deception for many shall come in my name
saying I am Christ and shall deceive
many so there's going to be a lot of
false prophets in the world and ye shall
hear of wars and rumors of wars it's
interesting language rumors of wars
could this be misinformation
disinformation you know is any of this
stuff really real what we hear on the
news or is it rumors for fear rumors to
cause fear and panic in the world see
that ye be not troubled for all these
things must come to pass but the end is
not yet for nation shall rise up against
nation and Kingdom shall rise up against
Kingdom and when you look at the
original language this nation against
nation is actually about races is eth
ethnics are going to rise up against
each other we see this today this whole
uh race war that's going going on that
the media is is feeding us saying
that uh that racism is is running abound
and it's it's causing us to not be able
to uh side together because it's all
about divide and conquer it's all about
order out of chaos and this is what's
happening and there shall be famines and
pestilences pestilences and earthquakes
in diverse places if you look at an
earthquake map you'll see more
earthquakes more frequent in various
places that have never seen earthquakes
before before than ever in history this
stuff is happening and I don't believe
all of it is natural I believe that
there's technology to make these things
happen all these are the beginning of
Sorrows and they shall deliver you up to
be afflicted and they shall kill you and
ye shall be hated of all Nations for my
name's sake Christ's name is his
character and if we have the character
of Christ the world is going to hate us
because we won't buy into uh one world
religion we won't buy into the coexist
movement because truth is truth there's
only one path Jesus said I am the way
the truth and the life there is no other
way to the father except through me
broad is the way to destruction there's
a narrow path that goes to a narrow door
and only few will find it and yet the
pope recently said that all paths lead
to God all religions lead to God that
they're all like different languages to
God how can that be true does that mean
Anton La the Satanist and Alistair
Crowley the wickedest man alive they're
going to be in the Kingdom because they
they were just speaking a different
language to God they were on a different
little path to God but they all lead to
the same God right it's not true this is
not the truth and if we compromise we
will be lost we must stand on thus
sayeth the Lord we can't buy into our
senses we can't buy into what we see
because we're going to be seeing a lot
of crazy things as the military is
telling us that UFOs are real that
non-human intelligences exist and they'
been in communication with them for
since the 1930s we're going to see a lot
of strange things but we cannot buy into
even what our senses tell us Jesus said
when they say uh that that he's returned
and he's in the in the desert don't even
go look because it's going to be so
deceptive you will fall for the
deception don't even go look when they
say he's in the secret chamber do not go
because if you see something like a
miracle working angel of Light who's
saying I am Christ you will fall for
that deception
we have to understand prophecy we have
to understand the timeline that there is
no pre-tribulation Rapture that the
millennial time period is actually in
heaven that this world's going to be a
desolate Earth there's so many things
that are wrapped up in Prophecy that can
confuse us if we don't understand it and
so many of these movies and everything
have been pushing the wrong
narrative and then shall many be
offended and shall betray one another
and shall hate one another and many
false prophet prophets many not a few
many false prophets shall rise and shall
deceive
many and because iniquity shall abound
the love of many shall wax cold we are
living in a time when iniquity
lawlessness is abounding the love of
many was drawing cold like you if you
don't have the same political belief I'm
not your friend anymore you might as
well unfriend me if you don't do this
and that oh you don't keep the holidays
you can't be my friend anymore there's
so many things that separate us from the
world and we will be hated and the love
of many will grow cold but but he that
shall endure to the end the same shall
be
saved and this Gospel of the Kingdom
shall be preached in all the world for a
witness unto the Nations and then shall
the End come when does The End come when
the gospel is spread to All Nations
that's the point of having a channel
like this that's the point of exposing
these satanic deceptions and lies and
reading the word of God and pointing
people get back to Christ get your
relationship right with him get rid of
all these distractions in your life get
in the word of God get in prayer draw
closer to him than ever before because
times are fixing to get hard and the
Bible tells us to flee to the mountains
get away from the cities because that's
where it's going to happen first where
all the people are compacted together
the Book of Revelation chapter 13 in
verse 16 talks about and he causes all
both small and and great rich and poor
free and bond to receive a mark in their
right hand or in their foreheads and
that no man might buy or sell save he
that had the Mark or the name of the
Beast or the number of his name don't
get me Twisted here the mark of the
beast is not a
microchip never take a microchip never
take any kind of technology in your
brain or in your hand but I'm telling
you right now you can avoid a microchip
at all cost and still be lost and still
take the mark of the beast because the
mark of the Beast is a forced system of
worship and that forced system of
worship you can take it two ways you can
either believe it with your mind and
your forehead and say this is true this
is peace this is coexist this is the
truth or you can say you know what I
don't want to die and I don't want my
family to die I'm going to go along with
the system I don't believe it in my
forehead but I'm going to go along with
it and that's the works of your hand
taking the mark in your hand remember
Revelation is symbolic God's people are
sealed with the seal of the Living God
in their foreheads and that's not
literal that's not physical neither is
the mark of the beast neither is a woman
standing on the moon clothed with the
sun neither is a a harlot on a
seven-headed dragon drinking the blood
of the Saints this is all symbolic we
are Israel symbolically the lost world
is Babylon which doesn't even exist
today all of this is symbolic please
Study Bible prophecy we're going to do
videos on this on these topics and we're
going to get into the word of God we're
going to get into Bible prophecy so that
none of us shall be
deceived thank you guys so much for all
your love and support thank you for
being here if you like this video please
give it a thumbs up it's a easy free way
to support this channel we have uh many
different options we have uh different
ways you can give digitally through cash
app or PayPal or vinmo or uh one of the
other ones zel we also have some
merchandise here you can see on our on
our website candid truth.org you can
look at the merchandise and these are
ways that you can spread the word you
can uh wear the the logo that talks
about it's cool to use your brain be
cool use your brain there's so much
propaganda in the world that makes it
look cool to be dumb and makes it look
uncool to be smart but that is that's
just what it is it's propaganda it's
it's a a system that's trying to dumb us
down so that we can be more easily
controlled if you guys want to if you
guys want to give if you feel led to
give to this ministry you can give
through cash app vinmo or
zel and we love you we thank you we
cannot do this without you please share
this video like it and if you're new
Please Subscribe we got a lot more
videos coming your way we'll see you
next time